Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome back to 'Unforgiving Northern Hym'
Now, I found out what these posters are all about. There's an option in the main menu called:
'Collected stories' and each of these has a poem.
Depicting one of the ancient stories of I imagine, Swedish lore. There's the various things like what we're seeing now.
They're collected all through the different chapters of the game and actually, I think the most recent one I found was...this one.
Which means that, we're in chapter 7 of a game of only nine chapters.
We may finish this game in this next chapter if,
I am diligent enough and don't die a million times over to stupid things that are completely preventable, but I'm doing my infinite ignorance
I'm unable to defeat. Anyway, so I don't think we can turn this on right now.
Oooh!
Yes, we can. Ah, how inspirational. Are these cans of gasoline?
Good that one was...empty? Full?
Empty.
Empty. Oh good, I'm finding the right one with which to do something terrible!
Noohohohoho.
-Italian laugh-
I found a winner! I found a winner. Okay, alright. the fall of the false god the false god
The fall of the false god -
The false god saw, how lovely Freya was and fell for her beauty.
He made plans to play as violin for her, charming her with his music. However, freya saw right through his ruse
Okay, alright. Well, it was a pretty nice ruse. Yeah, nobody would have fallen for that when they speak to you...
outside.
Trying to get you to....give him a harp of some sort.
Alright, was it up that one or was it up this one? I think it was this one??
Wasn't ain't up on this one?
Was it up this one?
Wasn't it up here storage?
Oh Hello!
(-darkness my old friend...)
Ahh yeah, no. I think that was definitely it. Okay well,
Everybody hold on to your hats...
Oh boy you may not I
-repeats what mother nature said- "You may not"
Ah, eugh :(
-mother crying- "There must be another way! Think of my child, please!"
-sound of gasoline being poured-
Oh geez. -baby fusses- Oh geez. Oh God. Oh, maybe I couldn't just like hacked off an arm. I
Eugh! Maybe I could of just hacked off an arm?
-mother still crying-
Eughhhh :(
-Mothers crying is progressively getting louder-
Don't want to do it! I don't, -striking matches- there's no other way!
Ah..
-both baby and mother are screaming in pain-
Aahh why? :'(
Ah, God
-some sort of clicking noise?- (idk if thats in-game or Mark is readjusting mic)
Well, aren't I so happy with myself?
Yeah, that trickster God doesn't want to mess with me. I'm crazy.
(we've known that for a while.)
Eugh God. Shat's so horrible. Why does the game make you do that?
-prepubescent Mark- Why'd you have to do that?! :'(
Why'd that tree lady have to...try to...keep her child safe right there?
Ahhh...
Man, do you think I'm the only one that's ever done that? Like, there's been so many options for people to try to
go into storage.
And they've been like "Nah! You know wha?t I'm not gonna do that horrible thing that is
is, * obviously* not even remotely a choice in my mind. Because, I'm not insane and I wouldn't do that."
But huhaha I come along and nope naw my first didn't think this to burn down *everything*
Dive deepest into depravity. Like, I've already torn my brothers tongue and eyeball out without even being prompted to that was just something that I did and then was like "Oh my God...Oh god....oh god."
I just -laughs- instantly dive into the worst scenario possible. No question, no hesitation, just right into it.
Oh my god. Hello,
How's it going there? Anybody want to tell me anything about? What's happening? You gonna slap me? >.> ... Okay
Okay, nobody slapped me. I'm already slapped...ugh.
Right into the water
Hate it, hate, hate, hate, hate. Hate, all this! This is what I hate this thing that I'm in right now?
I hate hate every bit of it
Hate, hate, hate! hate! hate! Oh, who dropped a turd? Oh! Hate! Hate! Hate tha-
I guess I'm going back at the water then. >:(
-Tarzan Mark- Ooooohhhhhhh
I'm dead. I'm dead. I'm dead, you can swim, too. Oh, that's not good. Okay well...
-laughs uncomfortably-
Ahh...
Okay, what are you doing? What are you doing?
"Swiggity swooty boi!"
-monster is groaning. Kinda sounds like a car that won't start tbh-
Please tell me that you're just gonna dive headfirst into that pool of light
"Oooo shiney o.o"
Good great. You look-okay good (roughly 15x)
Okay, here go! Alright.
Putting this log with me
(Long Log Larry?)
This game,
is awesome, and I love it. Why are we screaming now! Why is now-Okay.. Why is now the time to scream?
I asked myself at frequent times.
Okay, alright, whatever you say .-.
Wherever we're gonna go in here. I'm sure it's gonna be wonderful and delightful
Oh! who am I gonna burn down next?! Oh, good storage, good.
I'm glad that storage wasn't held that anywhere near the actual doorway into storage
It was it was deep in a pit filled with water and muck and horrible monsters
That's where I want to keep all my valuables. Oh, this is not a fondant picture. That's the worst picture. Okay, all right anyway
Hidden worlds 2 - There are theories that among the worlds of Hebrew the live about word there exists an underworld the purgatory a place where
Humans have to convent and plate prior choices and atone for their sins
*sort of high pitched* Hahaha, I like that door with the spikes on the top right there. That's a good one, huh?
(Try B to blow it)
Hehe
Why did I come in here? That's still the question that I have. Did I need to come in here?
I didn't-I don't know if I *need* anything.
We got hungry...
They ate the dog! T_T
(Go pet Chica! Now!)
Great! Okay, yeah, yeah, I can see that we got hungry. I miss Bobby oh man. Oh man. Oh
-continues to read the note/drawing- "We got hungry. I miss Bobby."
Oh man! Oh man. Ohohoho.... :'(
(Frikin go love on Chica!! ;-;)
The game just meant to make me feel terrible. -Reads cover of book- 'Hunting flying and cutting up living off the poor'
-continues- "Get it instructions on how to survive on the fourth" I get it! They ate the dog!
Ehehehehe that's horrible.
I hate youuu :'(
Ehhh that's the worst thing! ;_;
I'm so sad now! I am so sad!
That's so sad. What is this? I got a
-laughing-
pork?
-high pitched- I came all this way for that for a plug!
You know what? It's great. That's what I expected to happen after all this.
That's what I was anticipating everything about this is led up to that moment.
Yea, that makes sense to me of which that is that thing that happened to me
-monster comes out of portal-
"Swiggity swooty. Where's Becky?"
Why don't you dare? I will-I will slap the shit out of you, okay?
Yeah, you carry out on your stupid little loop your piece of Garpoo.
I will smack the piss out of you.
(Yea good luck with that)
I will send you into yesteryear mister! That's right! You better keep walking beeeeeitch.
Okay alright. Okay. Yeah, oh, what's that? Oh? Oh? Yeah walk away from your problems
(Get closer to him and we'll see who's walking/running away from their problems)
Oh, yeah, you suck! You ain't gonna do nothing bout it. Ah titty sprinkles! Come on! You want to fight?!
I'm right here! Right here! Come on! That's right. That's right. You go shut your frick frakking face
Oh, oh! Hey! Oh!
Another friend in the party room! Okay, which way am I going? Yeah, but I got an electrical cord again
Didn't even know if I needed it. Just happened. You gonna punch me? You're gonna slap me?
You know what? You should slap me because I just I want all this to end. Okay, see ya!
See ya! Man, I keep expecting them to slap me, but they know slap. How can they not slap?
(It's because they haven't paid that part of the internet yet)
I'm so slappable at this moment, but again. It's like is that a moral dilemma.
Is it like-like what kind of existence is that?
What existence is that is that any way to live is that a life worth living?
I say no if I was trapped in a tree for all eternity slave to another's will
Well what was the point then I
Hear something guys there, did you hear something? I think I heard something. I think I heard something
Hey
There was something over there
I heard oh, I hear skitters campers
And then I heard baby voices something tells me that the babies aren't gonna be too. Happy about my current course of actions I
Don't know what happened over here horrible demon babies in the darkness horrible dark darkness demon babies deep
All right, I can I can attest that is awful and I hate it
And I don't want anything to do with it, and if they come over here
I'll put a bunch of in their little baby faces I
Markiplier. I'm not afraid to punch a baby in the face in the means of survival in fact
I burnt one alive nor daddy might probably dead. I burnt it. It was a tree. I burnt a tree
That's all I want to say about that
So don't mess with me is the lesson that I'm teaching you right now because if you mess with me
I will let you on fire that
Is a lesson to be learned here. This is awful. Why do I have to go down here? I don't like this
Can the babies stop whining Oh little bitch babies down
Okay, you know I'm going right back up I
Don't want to go down there. Oh, I hate that I
Hate everything about that that is the worst thing I don't want to be here
This oh god I hate this I hate this so much
Oh, I hate this so much. No no no no no no none of this. I hate this so much guys
You don't understand how much V. I hate this. I hate it so much I
Hate it so much. Oh my god. I've never been this scared in a long time. I hate it so much
I hate this oh, I hate this No
Please I want to live that way why now oh?
Hey this um fine blind dear oh
God I hate it. I hate it. I hate it so much. I hate it so much. Oh god these damn it babies
No, it's it clearly a trap
I'm a big strong brave boy, but in the face of demon babies. I'm not okay. I'm not okay
Don't stop. I mean stop. Don't don't stop being you cute you little piece of shit, okay?
Are you little you little Scrabble a babbling baby gonna get the full face of?
Fist if you know what I'm talking about if you keep messing with me. All right. I will mess you up well
I will I will fight a baby. I will one hundred present fight a baby. I will I will slap a baby oh
I saw baby. I saw a baby. I saw that baby. I see you baby. No. I'm not okay with that, baby
Okay, all right
Do not like do not I do not like I'm gonna go this way cuz it's secret way around the baby Ward's gonna run
Right smack into the face of the baby am I gonna run smack into the face of the baby
I'm gonna run smack into the face of the baby
Okay, now that I've seen the baby. I think I'm relatively okay with the baby the baby is okay
The baby's everywhere
Everywhere baby's Oh, No why there's so many babies oh?
Well, there's so many babies I hit these babies okay, alright, so there's a baby right there
There's a baby making a loop I think I got a wait till it goes by cuz it's blind right. It's blind
Can't see me can only hear me
You know you know I understand. I just don't like babies apparently I mean babies are fine in all I guess
Where are the babies
Okay all right okay, so the baby can walk right by me, and that'd be fine. I just got to hide between behind medium box
bigglesworth yeah
Okay, all right. Well you think the tiny box Tim would be here to help me in this and oh no
No no no no no, I know no is that tiny bug step, where are you oh god? No, and don't like it, No
oh
That's the worst thing I've ever seen in my life
Oh, that's the worst thing. Oh, that's the worst thing. Oh god
Don't you don't stop oh
No oh oh no no no no no no no no no no no no no no I'm falling down. I'm falling down
Let me fall Oh
Scratched my eyes out. Okay. Well god damn it. I tried to fall down. I don't like these babies
Where am I where am I oh?
Wait wait wait wait where am I wait, what?
No no why no oh
Why where am I and why am I here I thought I was dead
I thought I would have just been a fun game over and I could I get to try again
You know that's usually how it works
It's like it's like the forest when you get dragged down into the the cannibal pile
Okay
There's no way out of here is there ah
I am just gonna be stuck here until they come and eat me
That's all I have to look forward to
Yep
Okay, I am doomed. I am doomed. Oh wait. What's that wait?
Where are you? Uh? What's in front of me hello? Hi I?
See a tree. Oh hello. You don't look so good. Okay, all right
Well that's strange okay wait there's nothing here, okay? What about it? Can I get over here yes?
This is bizarre
Why is this here? What is happening? I don't get it. I just don't get it. I don't understand it
I don't understand anything. That's happening here
Okay, all right well see ya see ya see ya. See ya
Okay, all right all right, okay, all right?
Why am I here again why why am I here?
How did it continue it
I don't get it
The fate of the unforgivable the Norns wasn't always so generous
Some humans were punished for their rotten souls in the form of purgatory and had to suffer through their worst nightmare over and over again
Until the Norns was satisfied break it break it break it break
would
Break what break? What what do I break? I'll break anything. I broke a family apart with fire and gasoline. I'll break anything
Don't like it mommy is sick ah
Mommy got bitten. Oh no wait oh, no no the punished they can hear you
I know that I know all about that I know about that oh
Man, I'm not looking so good. My arm is a little messed up
Okay, what do we have here?
Okay
Now let's stop being a little a little bitch, baby. I must start punching little bitch babies in their punchable faces
Okay everything's good
Okay now I'm dead now they hear you don't run, okay alright
That's I should have known that I knew that my panicked instinct told me to run and then I ran
So I just ran. I couldn't help it. I ran. That's all I did that's all I wanted to do. Yeah, oh
No, well, I can't see shit. Oh
That's awful. I hate that okay. Well. I'm gonna light a match. I suppose. I can't see where I'm going
Okay, that's that's the worst thing
It's a bunch of spongebob impersonators over there ah
It's like going to the world's worst spongebob convention boy
Okay, I realize like for this entire episode my face has been permanently stuck. Oh, I hate this okay, fern Elise buck like this
Okay, all right righty-ho then
Let's see you
Crawling again, I guess
Okay, I think I'm home free. I'm not gonna oh
No, nope nope when I said I was home free. I meant the opposite of that because there's many of you oh
There's so many of you. Okay. Well. There's a problem
Was this like planned was this planned there didn't seem to be a way to get out of there. Oh?
Boy, oh boy. Oh boy. Well I'm gonna be quiet oh
That's awful. Oh
What happened to the children in Sweden? This is what all Swedish children look like before they grow up
You could just grow up like this gremlins
Lurking in the caves. They lurk in the caves for a few years until they mature and then they come out and they're like
Hubert II hid and I'm fine now
Okay, I just gotta make it through this area. They definitely didn't hear that
Man this would be a bad time to discover that my game is listening to my microphone and listening to me shouting
rant and rave like a lunatic
In any other circumstance
Screaming at the top of my lungs is a good deterrent for evil, but now in this one moment
They need to be quiet as a mouse
Do I do
What do I do?
You just keep going. Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh, my god. Please keep going. Oh, oh oh no oh no
Who walks around I'm a dead man who walks around
I'm alive apparently okay, all right. I'm a live man. Who also whoo ow no one heard that
No one heard that
Howie there's so many babies how many babies did this town have how many babies? Oh?
How many babies how productive were these people Oh?
Haven't they heard out of a goddamn condom in this town
Okay all right oh
That's where it went. Oh good. I've been waiting to play my harp to you
I've been hoping and praying upon a star I wonder if I could have made this without getting caught like the initial time
I wonder if that was even an option or but if I like absolutely had to be caught no matter what okay?
Well either way, they're gonna hear this so is this troublesome. Can you look at the goddamn?
music sheet
Okay well I got that but my blood seems to be fully uh treed
Okay well
Okay, well they're pissed off at some did I do that I did the others me those. Oh, that was all me 100%. Oh
Dan near a thing stealth is the night
Okay
All right, man my pinky finger sure is getting tired of hitting this
Crouch button
Okay, I know where they are
Sam I
hear, I'm
like it oh
Don't like that
No paint it
Nothing behave
Where are they
It seemed right this don't feel right something right about this
You drop by me, it sounds like it's right by me
Sounds like it's right by me, okay. It's fine. It's fine. I think it's fine. I think it's fine
I'm not 100% percent sure about anything in this time, but I think it's fine
He's just designed to make me think they're all right by me
Not gonna run though no need to run. Why would I run runnings for losers?
Okay
Just gonna calmly walk ignore that just gonna calmly walk calmly walking
Calmly
walking
calm
calmly
walking
I'm running now. I'm gonna run now. I am extremely running now. Oh
Runnin runnin runnin runnin runnin runnin runnin there's a good thing I love running
There's something by me should I look behind me? I really want to look behind me huh oh?
I want to look behind me oh
"Excuse me sir, have you hear of the good word?"
No oh no oh no, there's a lot of bones, how are this many people in this town?
This time oh
I'm dead. I'm dead. I'm dead. I'm dead
I'm dead hey you wanna you want to listen to a tune you listen to a jaunty tune
Okay, I'll play you a jaunty tune
Okay kids
This is uh?
This is what I call Wonderwall
Hope you liked it
Wonder how this wall is gonna. Go away. Huh well watch this. These are some big bones. Those are big bones
Those are some big bones all right well
Then I'll see you around kids see their kids. Have a good one
Wear that what
Hopa Hopa
Well that's a lot of medication wait a minute, that's a lot of medication, that's a lot of medication
Wait hang on there's a lot of medication and needles
Was this all just a figment of my imagination
He did he not shout at me to jump
Getting really loud in here
Let's get in quite loud
Maybe you could not do that
Is there any other way besides jumping
All right, thank you, I guess uh
Why is it so goopy
What
The hell happened oh hi oh good
Hello
-crazy fan-girl laughs manically-
How about no no how about no how about no how about
"Omg I touched something that senpai had!"
-continues to laugh manically
-laughs manically-
So I should turn around and run is what you're saying I should turn around and run probably
Big
Good
Funny about all this bump all right well bizarre
Wonderful ah thank you for that mmm great skin treatment the steam what happened where am I?
Complete the circle
I
Can't fucking see
To me
What is good to see ya I
Didn't have a choice. I didn't do nothing Oh God. Oh
Stuck in an endless loop of torture. That's awful is horrible. Ah
Man ah
That's so cool
But I wonder if there was a way to break loose of the cycle
somewhere in the game like if you found all the secret pieces, or if you found some secret thing in the game, I wondered I
Have no idea if there was another way because they didn't give me any choice at the end there
But maybe there was like another like
Avenue that you could have taken like if I had gotten all the way down there without being captured by those little things
Maybe then I would have found something there would have been a little bit better, but then I just wasn't good enough
I guess so I'll leave it up to you guys if you guys know of a different way to go through it or you want
To find out for yourself
I'll put a link to the game in the description below and just thank you everybody so much for watching
Let me know what you thought down in the comments below and as always I will see you in the next video